[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le journal de tv soixante
dix huit pour un condensé d'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres de ce mercredi 23
octobre
jusqu'à vendredi la commune des
clayes-sous-bois question de la
parentalité avec une semaine dédiée
ateliers spectacles et conférences à
destination des familles le thème cette
année l'incursion des écrans dans notre
quotidien le 7 octobre dernier la
fondation abbé-pierre alerter sur l'état
du mal logement en ile-de-france 1,2
million de personnes seraient concernées
dans la région à la fondation présente
son éclairage dans plusieurs villes du
territoire étape demain à trappes
et puis la fusion yvelines
hauts-de-seine se poursuit enclenchée en
2016 le rapprochement entre les deux
collectivités connaît une nouvelle étape
l'agencé d'insertion professionnelle
activity et devient inter départements
très inter départementale entre le 78 et
le 92
cette information avant de développer
ces titres le crash d'un avion de
tourisme a fait deux morts hier à
l'aérodrome de chavenay villepreux un
instructeur et son élève sont décédés
après la chute de leur aéronef vers 16
heures dans un champ à 250 mètres de la
piste selon les premiers éléments
l'appareil de type ulm était en phase
finale d'atterrissage lors de l'accident
la brigade de gendarmerie des transports
aériens de toussus le noble et la
section de recherches et des transports
aériens de roissy sont en charge de
l'enquêté il s'agit du quatrième crash
d'avion en deux mois dans le département
le troisième qui est mortelle une crise
du logement insoluble en ile de france
d'après la fondation abbé pierre le 7
octobre dernier à l'alerter sur la
question du mal logement dans la région
1,2 million de personnes seraient
concernées par cette question du mal
logement la fondation abbé pierre
présente son éclairage dans plusieurs
villes franciliennes étape demain et
jeudi attrapés pour en parler eric
constantin bonsoir enfin vous êtes le
directeur de l'agencé régionale ile de
france de la fondation abbé pierre pour
quoi vous parlez d'une christine d'une
crise par non insoluble du logement
parce que ça fait déjà plusieurs années
qu'on parle de crise du logement et
qu'on est dans une région aujourd'hui
zone très tendue on a pu avec cette 2e
éclairage régional à avoir des chiffres
qui montrent aujourd'hui l'importance de
la situation du mal-logement donc sur
les 4 millions de mal-logés aujourd'hui
au niveau national vous avez un plus
d'un million de personnes qui sont mal
logés qui vivent en ile de france
c'est 10 % des franciliens qui sont dans
cette situation et c'est un paradoxe
puisque c'est 1,2 millions de mal logés
sont dans une région qui est à l inverse
la plus riche enseignement la plus riche
au niveau national après quand tout vous
regardez de plus près les chiffres de
sur la pauvreté faut savoir que l'île de
france est aussi la région où la
proportion de pauvres a augmenté le plus
rapide le plus vite par rapport aux
autres aux autres régions et le taux de
pauvreté est supérieur en région ile de
france au niveau du taux de pauvreté
national dans votre éclairage ans elle a
dit à cette situation concerne 1,2
million de personnes en ile-de-france à
partir de quel moment on est on est
considéré comme mal logé
c'est compliqué à avoir mais quand vous
regardez ses 1,2 million vous avez déjà
la forme la plus alarmante du mal
logement qu'elle nos logements quand
vous êtes comme vous n'avez pas de
domicile personnel
au delà vous avez toutes ces personnes
qui sont dans des situations de
logements dégradés inconfortable avec
des risques parfois pour la santé ou la
sécurité et puis vous avez aussi toutes
les personnes qui sont dans des
logements trop petits par rapport à leur
composition familiale et on entend trop
petit à partir du moment où vous avez
plus deux pièces en moins par rapport à
votre composition et puis à la marge
mais faut pas les oublier vous avez
aussi les gens du voyage aujourd'hui
avec quelques dizaines de quelques
centaines de noms de personnes qui sont
coincés dans des aires d'accueil
faute d'avoir des terrains familiaux
alors qu'eux ils peuvent être en voie de
sédentarisation et comment elle explique
alors aujourd'hui cette crise du
logement est ce qu'il faut trouver une
raison dans les logements sociaux le
rythme de construction qui n'est pas
respecté ce que c'est l'une des raisons
il y en a d'autres
vous avez raison il ya 2
aujourd'hui de concentrer une dynamique
insuffisante dans la construction de
logements y compris de logements sociaux
paradoxalement parce que cette région
est plein de paradoxes paradoxalement de
la région ile de france et aussi la
région qui produit le plus de logements
sociaux mais on a pris du retard on n'a
jamais été au niveau des objectifs qu'on
s'était assignée depuis les années 90 on
est à 50 60 maintenant depuis 2010 on
doit être à 70000 logements par an on
est depuis 2010 en retard donc on sait
que maintenant il faut passer à 78 mille
logements par an pour rattraper ce
retard est aussi pouvoir permettre aux
gens de se loger correctement d'eau fait
pas suffisamment de logements
vous avez les coûts du logement qui ont
explosé avec ce même si en ile de france
les salaires sont supérieurs à la
moyenne nationale en moyenne 25%
supérieur à la moyenne nationale mais la
location ses 52 % plus cher et non
parlons pas de l'acquisition on est là à
160 % plus cher en ile de france qu'au
niveau national
alors avec cet éclairage régional et
cette série de tables rondes dont on va
parler dans un instant que vous
organisez sur le territoire quel est
l'objectif finalement cessé de remettre
cette question du mal logement au coeur
du débat sur le logement le débat actuel
sur le logement c'est sermet la question
du logement et c'est aussi surtout
remettre les personnes mal logées au
coeur du débat puisqu'il ne faut pas
oublier que derrière tout ce chiffre on
dit beaucoup de chiffres il ya il ya
quand même des situations familiales
personnelles vous avez des personnes
isolées connais des femmes avec enfants
vous avez les couples qui vivent une
situation dramatique donc c'est déjà
reparler des personnes et de cette
diversité
et puis d'aller effectivement
sensibilisés par les interpeller on est
aussi dans une phase intéressante
puisque nous allons avoir des
municipales et prochaine des régionales
l'année suivante donc on est aussi là
pour sensibiliser les élus à ce qui se
passe sur le territoire francilien
donc c'est pour ça que vous allez dans
différentes villes franciliennes sur la
raison est simple on peut pas on ne peut
pas parler d'un éclairage régionales si
on bat qu'à paris la région ne se limite
pas à paris et c'est pour ça qu'on a
choisi délibérément d'aller dans quatre
autres villes d'ile-de-france d'aller
dans des villes où on avait des
associations partenaires c'est à dire
des associations soutenues par la
fondation puisque la fondation faut pas
l'oublier c'est la mode
où vit grâce aux dons de la générosité
du public et avec ses doigts elle permet
de financer les associations
donc nous avons choisi quatre villes
nous nous sommes allés à vitry à
clichy-sous-bois la semaine dernière
donc nous serons à trappes demain et la
semaine prochaine nous irons à
clichy-la-garenne étudiants pour le
moment de ces tables rondes parce que ça
intéresse justement cette thématique we
ll et les tables rondes aujourd'hui les
salles font effectivement sont complètes
il ya aussi une interaction c'est aussi
ça qui est intéressant c'est à dire que
vous avez des questions qui sont posées
par exemple acquis clichy sous bois on
va parler on a parlé de la prévention
des expulsions
vous aviez des personnes de paris duval
demain qui venait aussi proposer des
solutions puisque l'expulsion est un
phénomène aujourd'hui en augmentation en
ile de france et on est une région qui
expulse beaucoup avec une logique
répressive donc c'est aussi important de
faire discuter des personnes qui sont
pas forcément sur les mêmes territoires
et qui ont peut-être des choses à sa
portée à chaque table eux même si il ya
en début à chaque fois la représentation
de cet éclairage est une thématique
propre à chaque fois à trappes demain 14
heures salle gravaud la question posée
c'est ce que la dématérialisation est un
plus pour l'accès au logement des jeunes
pourquoi cette thématique
alors cette thématique on l'a on la
choisit avec notre partenaire nom qui
est le claj 50 ans ni ville qui va
animer la table ronde
donc le claj comité local pour le
logement autonome des jeunes qui reçoit
une population moins de 30 ans et en
fait quand on parle de dématérialisation
on pense souvent à la fracture numérique
qui peut concerner des personnes âgées
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de manier
l'outil informatique
eh bien on s'aperçoit que dans des lieux
comme ses classes vous avez des jeunes
qui arrivent et qui ne peuvent pas ou
qui ne savent pas utiliser cet outil
pour faire des démarches administratives
et aujourd'hui accéder à un logement
notamment accéder à un logement hlm
tout est dématérialisé donc il est
important de faire en sorte que c'est le
jeune qui sont aussi un public important
en matière de personnes publiques mal
logés donc faire en sorte qu'ils aient
accès à ces droits et pour avoir accès à
ces droits donc il ya demain lors de la
table ronde vous aurez par exemple
l'association droit d'urgence qui
viendra nous présenter ce qu'elle a mis
en place sur paris
voilà vous avez différents acteurs qui
ont testé déjà des choses qui marchent
pour faire en sorte que les jeunes aient
accès à
moi le programme j'imagine c'est la
présentation de cet éclairage d échanges
et de faire participer aussi le public
présent là on est ouvert au public
on est sur une présentation et après à
des questions réponses c'est aussi la
fondation présente son regard donc c'est
tout le monde ne sera peut-être pas
forcément d'accord avec ce que nous
avançons mais c'est aussi ces moments de
débattre avec les habitants les
franciliennes et franciliens qu'on
rencontre à vitry on avait beaucoup
d'habitants des quartiers populaires qui
sont venus aussi proposé puisque c'est
aussi dans notre éclairage un des axes
un des enjeux qu'on soulève c'est à dire
de la participation des habitants à
résoudre et à répondre à leurs besoins
et à proposer être force de proposition
et on rappelle que cette table ronde est
au programme demain jeudi à trappes
accueille dès 13h30 le début c'est à 14h
à la salle aggravons et on peut
s'inscrire à bien le lien qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci eric constantin
est repassé en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de l'agencé
régionale ile de france de la fondation
abbé pierre dans l'actualité toujours du
côté de trappes une oeuvre détériorer la
sculpture de nicolas sanhes installé la
semaine dernière place arnaud beltrame a
été taguée est de couleur blanche la
réalisation a été peinturluré dans un
communiqué trappe s'est indigné de cet
acte une atteinte aux biens publics et à
la propriété intellectuelle écrit la
ville rappelons que l'oeuvre a été érigé
sur la place arnaud beltrame en hommage
au lieutenant colonel de gendarmerie
tués dans l'attentât de trèbes le 23
mars 2018 il avait pris la place d'un
otage
c'est en ce moment la troisième édition
de la semaine de la parentalité ou
clayes-sous-bois elle est au programme
jusqu'à vendredi plusieurs ateliers sont
organisés
parmi eux un atelier de massage pour
bébé à l'espace jacqueline auriol ce
matin manon varaldo a assisté à cette
animation
on enlève des tensions angelo semblent
plus détendus et cela grâce au massage
sa mère katherine est venu assister à
cet atelier dirigé sous les conseils de
séverine dans le montre qu'on est là
qu'on se prépare on se réchauffe les
mares petite pression sur les pieds
massage papillon pour les jambes
la mère de famille apprend les bons
gestes pour un massage relaxant
il ne faut jamais lâcher le contact avec
son bébé lors du massage l'enfant doit
toujours vous sentir vous pouvez placer
vos pouces au niveau du front et vous
laisser un deux trois petits chefs et on
y est essentielle ils n'ont pas de sens
ces massages stimule le développement
sensoriel il est conseillé de les faire
sur le lit parental et d'instaurer un
rituel lumière tamisée et musicalement
fond c'est un massage bien-être par un
massage thérapeutique et
c'est surtout un moment privilégié avec
entre l'enfant et son parent des
massages aux visages sont également
appris lors de l'atelier ils peuvent
soulager notamment la poussée des dents
des tout petits la mer d'angelo profite
de ce moment de partage avec son fils
c'est pour créer un lien et que et ça
descend ça permet de détendre passâmes
ont prévilégié ensemble et faire une
petite parenthèse dans la vie du
quotidien
ça m'a donné encore plus envie de
poursuivre dans ce sens là et puis de
d'apprendre de nouveaux gestes pour
masser mon bébé j'ai l'impression que ça
lui a fait du bien donc c'est que du
bonheur un moment de douceur entre
parents et enfants qui se reproduira à
domicile et pour parler justement de
cette semaine de la parentalité cécile
la gale bonsoir ça vous est la
responsable du service jeunesse et vie
de quartier aux clayes-sous-bois une
troisième édition de cette semaine qui a
démarré depuis le 16 octobre
est ce que le succès déjà est au rendez
vous cette année oui on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de nouvelles personnes qui sont
venues nous voir et et ça s'explique
aussi par la diversité des actions qu'on
a pu mettre en place cette année et
c'est agréable on aura l'occasion de
présenter le reste des animations pour
la semaine pourquoi organiser cet
événement à la base est ce qu'il y avait
une demande des parents d'être orienté
d'être aidés par laurie oui et c'est
surtout une démission d'un centre social
c'est le soutien à la parentalité aux
familles donc
du coup on a voulu créer un événement
autour de deux thèmes du quotidien pour
les les familles mais le thème de cette
année les écrans entre patients et
poison c'est surtout à la un thème
d'actualité et c'est à la demande du
public des des partenaires aussi et puis
et puis
et ça fait partie de notre quotidien
aujourd'hui du coup les objectifs de
l'évènement c'est informer sensibiliser
sur c'est sur ces thématiques mais
sensibiliser dédramatiser aussi puisque
c'est apprendre à vivre avec et avoir
une certaine éducation pour éviter qu'on
qu'on ait des dérives et vous le disais
c'est important de donner ses clés aux
parents c'est ça fait partie des
démissions d'un centre social
tout à fait alors vous le disiez le
thème cette année l'incursion des écrans
dans notre quotidien avec forcément la
télé les ordinateurs le smartphone la
tablette même les objets connectés
maintenant ils se sont multipliés dans
le quotidien des foyers et ça influence
forcément l'avis des foyers justement
oui oui oui on a fait des questionnaires
enfin voilà on a eu des retours
aujourd'hui c'est s'il ya plus de cet
écran non je n'en chaque foyer en
moyenne donc c'est énorme ça fait partie
des demandes des parents d'avoir une
thématique sur sur les aiguilles écran
n'est alors justement dans le cadre de
cette semaine de la parentalité une
exposition intitulée comprends moi se
déroule à l'espace sémaphore
l'association ensemble pour l'éducation
de la petite enfance rassemble des
connaissances international sur le
développement de l'enfant comprend moi
est un parcours pédagogique avec 80
panneaux ludiques divisé en six
thématiques sont expliqués notamment lé
dont j'ai dû numérique pour les enfants
à taiwan par exemple les écrans sont vus
comme une maltraitance et ce ne sont
utilisées avec après trois ans d'une
manière très réfléchie écouter ses
propos recueillis par manon varaldo nos
enfants ne sont pas des adultes en
miniature nos enfants ne sont pas prêts
à recevoir la lumière bleue de l'écran
mais aussi les messages
et cette ce côté très froid de l'écran
qui n'est jamais un humain qui ne peut
jamais interagir de façon humaine avec
ce bébé qui n'est pas un adulte en
miniature qui était un tout petit et qui
a besoin d'abord de la tension
privilégié des adultes qui interagissent
avec lui mais dans cette exposition
aussi un arbre hameau est également mise
à disposition pour les enfants ils
peuvent écrire un sentiment un marquants
de leur enfant sur cet arbre
on l'a vu au treuil et pas que les
enfants d'ailleurs les parents aussi
c'est important de le préciser
on l'a vu dans cette exposition les
écrans ils peuvent avoir des effets
positifs dans dans le développement de
l'enfant mais ça peut aussi avoir un
esprit un aspect négatif c'est sa 6éme à
l'utiliser si c'est trop tôt a
effectivement et vous le disais tout à
l'heure il ya diverses actions qui sont
mises en place pour cette semaine de la
parentalité alors entre autres ateliers
spectacles projections cinéma
conférences ça c'était une volonté de
proposer une multitude d'activités
d'animation et pour aborder les sujets à
travers plusieurs supports qui permet de
répondre à tout le monde en fait ça
suscite l'envi pour certains qui
viendrait pas forcément une conférence
qui est rappelé pour un ciné débat et
voilà alors qu'est-ce qui a pu avoir par
exemple comme animation là depuis une
semaine
quelques exemples il ya eu comme vous
l'avez vu dans le reportage des ateliers
massage bébé et de portage aussi il ya
eu on a fait un partenariat avec
une école maternelle où on a fait venir
on a invité l'ensemble des parents à
venir découvrir comment construire des
jeux facilement avec des choses du
quotidien et partager des moments de
jeux de société etc
et puis on a fini avec un repas partagé
un spectacle de théâtre forum sur sur
les thématiques des écrans et puis
d'autres pour les plus petits la septème
spectacle dansé de finalement permettre
aux parents de passer un moment avec
leurs enfants tout à fait et de et que
les écrans deviennent pas des écrans
baby sitter comme on peut l'entendre
beaucoup dans l'actualité et donc ça
c'est pour le programme qui est déjà
passée ça se poursuit jusqu'à vendredi
que ce qu'est ce qu'il reste au prix d
une nocturne de l'exposition qu'on a vu
demain jusqu'à 20 heures au centre
social de sémaphore voilà il reste un
ciné débat demain matin sur le monde les
membres de ralph on a encore un
spectacle pour en direction des parents
des adolescents vendredi soir
c'est du théâtre forum aussi c'est le
même spectacle pour les petites vendredi
dernier mais là c'est adapté pour les
plus grands donc voilà il reste des
ateliers de codage pour apprendre
autrement il ya encore une multitude de
petites choses dans l'animation qu'on
retrouve sur le site internet des clayes
sous bois qui s'affiche ces animations
elles sont gratuites
oui sauf
sauf une sortie qu'on a faits au musée
du jouet qui était fort et des
animations pour le moment elles sont
gratuites alors vous le disiez c'est
déjà un succès et quels sont vos
espérances là d'ici vendredi pour la fin
de cette semaine
du coup nos espérances et de continuer à
recevoir le maximum de monde qui
s'intéresse à au sujet avec qui on peut
échanger et de l'or lors de faire des
apports éducatif d'apporter des réponses
et ça sera déjà beaucoup et cette
troisième semaine de la parentalité elle
et jusqu'à vendredi je le disais
l'ensemble du programme
à retrouver sur le site internet des
clayes-sous-bois merci c'est si la gale
est revenue en plateau responsable du
service jeunesse et vie de quartier pour
cette commune des clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
nouvelle étape dans la fusion des
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine les élus des deux
collectivités ont voté au sein de leurs
assemblées respectives
la transformation d'activité en une
agence inter départemental d'insertion
alors pour décrypter ce sujet nicolas
dandrimont soir bonsoir
grégory de la rédaction de tv 78 qu'est
ce que ça change concrètement cette
transformation
c'est la dernière étape l'aboutissement
de la politique inter départemental
d'insertion des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
l'agencé activity va dorénavant
s'occuper des deux territoires en
proposant des dispositifs de retour à
l'emploi au public illinois et au public
à dos et quan et les habitantes des
hauts-de-seine mais rappelez-vous
grégory cette démarche de mutualisation
des outils de politique d'insertion
avait déjà commencé en septembre 2018
avec l'adhésion des hauts-de-seine
activity puis en mars 2010neuf avec
l'inauguration d'une plateforme commune
jobs 92 et job 78 un site internet
regroupant regroupant des offres
d'emplois sur les deux territoires
ce rapprochement se poursuit en vue
peut-être d'une éventuelle fusion est ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler ce qu'est
activity activity c'est une agence
d'insertion créé par le conseil
départemental des yvelines ans en 2015
sa priorité la réinsertion par l'emploi
des personnes en situation de précarité
ce peut être les bénéficiaires du rsa
dont le département
s'occupent les chômeurs de longue durée
ou les populations des quartiers
politique de la ville son objectif
accompagner ces personnes en leur
proposant un parcours de retour à
l'emploi
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
concrètement comment ça se passe alors
cette agence développe différents
dispositifs pouvant aider à la
réinsertion
un retour directement à l'emploi prises
en charge par le département
vous savez qu'il a différentes
compétences notamment dans les collèges
c'est aussi organiser des événements un
peu innovant comme un match de football
entre recruteurs et demandeurs d'emploi
qui a été organisée à guyancourt donc
des choses plus original puis final
voilà l'idée en fait le coeur d'activité
d'activité c'est de penser d'innover
dans les démarches de retour à l'emploi
et c'est aussi l'orientation de
personnes vers des formations vers des
secteurs plus tôt en tension les
secteurs en tension ce sont des secteurs
qui ont du mal à recruter le btp le
numérique ou le service à la personne
dans le département des yvelines mais
c'est aussi le cas dans les
hauts-de-seine et pour cela activity
nouent des partenariats avec saint
quentin en yvelines par exemple des
collectivités avec des structures de
formation comme l'école de la nouvelle
chance et des entreprises directement
aussi qu'ils recherchent des des
personnes employées
si on fait un bilan de l'année 2018 plus
de 4000 yvelinois accompagné près de
1800 repris une activité 6 ans sont en
formation et depuis sa création en 2016
lagence a permis à 5000 yvelinois de
retrouver un emploi ou une formation
qualifiante
merci nicolas pour ce point
d'information et donc une nouvelle étape
de franchie dans cette fusion lancé
depuis 2016 entre le département des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
[Musique]
mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma jour
de notre petit tour vous en avez
l'habitude dans les salles du territoire
ce midi patrick jacques de dixmude et
michael et demi d'euros sont allés
recueillir quelques avis en sortie de
salle à l'ugcaa skywest première
impression notamment sur hors norme
réaliser coréalisé par le versaillais
eric toledano et sur le film d'animation
abominable
[Musique]
cette association répond au besoin dans
l'urgence alex était patient que la
société refuse ou qui semblent
impossibles à améliorer
[Applaudissements]
je recommande vraiment qu'on va aller
voir ce film c'est au moins un super
film est à tout point de vue vraiment
très très émouvant tous les cas c'est
tout chaud c'est éprouvant et en même
temps si ces merveilleuses qui font
vraiment très juste
avec un jeu d'acteur fantastique et puis
et puis dans une certaine réalité qui
est qui qui nous laisse un genou laisse
pantois qui ça arrive à les sortir un
petit peu quand même du néant
salut petit ou petite wii est confiante
tu es bien gars c'est pas tout tu viens
de moi aussi
et s'est échappé jaffer récupérer
marietti j'ai adoré c'était trop cool
j'ai bien aimé film parce il et il a
bien été réalisée c'est très bien et il
faut protéger les animaux c'est pour les
enfants c'est un bon moment il ya des
musiques sympa c'est joli c'est une
histoire
qui se laisse regarder c'est plutôt
familiale tout le monde peut y aller les
petits les grands les moyens pour tout
le monde et puis on referme ce journal
au château de versailles où 350 mille
arbres orne le domaine pour leur rendre
hommage
un parcours a été créée par les
jardiniers on va le suivre ce parcours
tout de suite avec mathilde et demi et
mélanie poké excusez moi j'étais en
train d'écouter alain baraton le
jardinier en chef du domaine de trianon
30 am ont été recensées par les équipes
du château dans un circuit d'arbres
admirable allons les découvrir
[Musique]
sylvain parent bonjour mélanie vous êtes
les gestionnaires du patrimoine arboré
du domaine déjà pourquoi avoir choisi de
mettre en avant ces arbres on a voulu
mettre en avant les arbres admirable du
château de versailles
parce que pour nous c'est pas nous
jardinier c'est un patrimoine très
important parfois un peu méconnue alors
par exemple celui ci qui est derrière
nous ce très vieux chêne qui est le plus
vieux vieilles arbres du domaine il a
trois cent soixante-cinq ans a survécu à
la tempête de 99 et à bien d'autres il a
survécu aux sécheresses il a survécu à
la révolution et c'est pour ça qu'on
voulait absolument qu'ils fassent partie
de notre de notre parcours il est très
certainement arriver là tout seul mais
il est fort à parier que louis xiv et
andré le nôtre sont passés sous ses
frondaisons assez régulièrement
on a vu un on fait un petit bout d'chou
on va aller en voir d'autres on a encore
quelques autres du côté du petit trianon
par exemple
trente cas ont été identifiés par les
équipes du château en fonction de leur
âge ou de leur rapport à l'histoire
les jardiniers se sont inspirés du label
arbre remarquable
enfin ça c'est un l'étreinte c'est un
sophora du japon c'est bien ça tout à
fait c'est un sophora du japon l'île à
presque 200 ans et il est contemporain
de marie antoinette en fait celui là on
est sûr que c'est elle même la jeune
reine qui a demandé à ce qu'on plante un
arbre ici à cet endroit là pour qu'elle
puisse le voir depuis les fenêtres du
petit trianon et elle voulait également
un arbre asiatique un arbre exotique et
on est certain que marie-antoinette
passer le voir très souvent aimé
beaucoup cet arbre est donc c'est pour
ça qu'il est venu s'intégrer dans la
collection des arbres admirable merci
ses ventes alors des arbres il y en a
partout et je vous propose maintenant
qu'on aille à l'orangerie
à l'orangerie cinq spécimens ont été
identifiés alors voilà un grenadier qui
est moi je les aime beaucoup parce que
j'aime l'aspect torturé comme ça du
tronc ce côté un peu baroque associé à
la régularité
là on est vraiment dans le jardin on va
dire régulier cette ce jardin maîtrisé
par cette nature maîtrisée par l'homme
profitait de ces arbres admirable il
vous faut pas grand-chose il vous faut
votre téléphone
des écouteurs télécharger l'application
il ne vous reste plus qu'à en profiter
moi il me reste encore une vingtaine je
vais y aller chez voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]